Okay.
My name is Donovan McNabb.
Since 2001 the Donovan McNabb foundation
has continued to spread the awareness
of diabetes.
Diabetes is something that's continued
to drastically terror the lives of some
of our individuals.
The high percentage of of individuals
are passing away from their families and
their loved ones.
We need to go out and find the
cure for this particular disease.
Obesity is something that
obviously adds into a diabetes.
Being overweight,
putting the wrong foods until your system.
I think we can eliminate that.
Diabetes is continued to grow over the
years with all of us come together.
We can continue to make a change.
Let's work together to end child obesity.
Let's invest in our nation's youth.